[Music]
me
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what's going on you guys
lord add it gave me addict i i i assumed
some of you noticed that we're not we're
not on wednesday we're on sunday and uh
you know i might have potentially
hijacked the uh the iop day you know
maybe i told cog
and king this is my day now sunday is my
day but all you guys know iop gonna be
wednesday
no i'm joking we have uh we have two
people
that
couldn't make it for iop so you know we
didn't want to leave you guys for
anything clearly you know this isn't iop
um
guys you could clearly tell from the
thumbnail it was an iop if you didn't
pay attention i guess you just wasn't
paying attention
but we're gonna get on with the show man
i got two people with here man i got
hustle and motivate my co-host what's
going on hustle
oh man not too much not too much um i
hope all is well happy holidays to
everybody whether you're celebrating
that um i want y'all to be safe if you
got the fireworks you know don't blow
your arm off like a homeboy in white
city um you know it's all good i just
want y'all to be safe and be happy
outside of that addict yo ain't nothing
going
dealing with some light things and it
looks like everything is about to even
out in mello water as you know and
it looked like everything about to be
cool man it's about to be a very good
summer for me um how about you sir
what's been going on
pretty good uh you know i have a lot
going on i've been playing cuphead i've
been playing a lot of final fantasy 10
like an absurd amount
you know
that's why i always be telling like i
actually be playing these japanese games
people be like addict you cap and you
don't play these nah people people don't
pay attention if they think i don't play
the japanese games but we got we got
dirt griggity man what is that bat oh
that's a gears of war background yeah
yes
award today yeah little gears
what's up y'all how you doing man what
you been playing uh nothing much well
i've been um um
i mentioned this last time but i just
finished the quarry recently
um it was a pretty good game if you like
those types of games
three of my characters died so i was
upset about that but you know it is what
it is um then i actually started um
playing a little halo
excuse me
then actually uh played a little lost
judgement you know i bought the game at
launch last year never played it so i
said it's time to pull it up
yeah we
got a got a pretty good show for you
guys uh ken smith will be here
eventually uh you know he told me he
would he had uh to do the family thing
and he would be showing up to his house
around one so he said he'd probably be
10 15 minutes late uh got a two
super chat from lord mayor hoof
hello uh
randolph or brother good day to you sir
man
i have to
cognito
now because you showed a picture of rand
everybody's saying we look alike
i personally feel like it's all white
people look alike that's what i
personally feel like you got a beard man
you look like lord cognition look look
at look like addict and rant
look man no eddie you i don't know about
y'all too looking like you know who
randolph thought does look like it
looked like rick rubin the producer back
in the 80s he um he helped what's the
name found def jam that's what we look
like that's what it looked like but it
was it was cool to see them too like
link up like that i was a little
surprised we don't see rand on camera
like this so anytime he does take a
picture and he like kind of you know
shows us i'm surprised he took the
picture to be honest with you
um well that's true that's true part of
you thought that he would be like oh
take this picture right and be like nah
i'm good
all right so you know we as you guys
could see we got a killer show for you
guys we got a little bit of salt today a
little bit a little bit of spiciness i'm
sure i'm sure dirt would love that uh so
you know
we got
halo continues to sell despite what
happened last generation they're selling
good in japan we got god of war and the
fiasco going on with that there's like
there's layers to that like
just just like um what's his name i
can't uh
no doc uh
uh what's his name um
brother
oh doc uh
dak dark 1985.
yeah yeah yeah yeah shout out to him
in that god of war fiasco
halo infinite there's a couple things we
need to go over with halo infinite uh
you know
we're gonna get break that down a little
bit i know we've talked about halo
infinite a lot but i do feel like it
needs to be brought up for good and bad
and then we got japanese games missing
xbox once again
i saw what you know what what do you
guys want to talk about first i'm sure
i'm sure
it's up to you brother
the god of war thing you guys want to
get oh man what should we like
let's let's lay for smooth for that
let's talk about something smooth don't
play japanese games missing xbox
all right so for those of you of the the
mega man
collection uh you know they they have
like kind of an uh kind of like a
turn-based grid space game collection
now they were on game boy i played a
couple of them and they were really good
games and
i've i heard rumors
probably six months ago that this game
was coming to the platforms i honestly
thought it was just a switch so when i
found out it was coming to pc and
playstation it was kind of a bonus but
man you look on there
dirt you look on there and there's
there's only one platform
there's only one
platform missing and it kind of
surprised me because capcom's normally
have been pretty good on making sure
that it goes everywhere so you know what
i want to hear from you guys is do you
think there's any particular reason this
stuff's going on
um well i will say this they have come a
long way when you compare last
generation they literally had no damn
japanese games on the platform it's like
they've come a long way
they're not fully there yet uh so
they're still gonna have some games
missing
unfortunately um the reason why
obviously i have no idea
i have absolutely no idea xbox is
selling much better in japan
um so i just truly don't know why this
mega man game is not on the platform
i don't know maybe they just
said uh nobody's gonna play it on xbox i
don't know you know i obviously don't
know but
i still think xbox is showing a lot of
progress
in japan and as well as having japanese
games that you know some xbox fans
wanted you know a lot of xbox fans like
yo man where we getting persona when
we're getting this game now like i said
not all of them are there
but you know they gotta take baby steps
i guess but it's unfortunate to see
another game skipping another japanese
game skipping this box
man
publisher too that's the part that blows
my mind
well i'm gonna keep it all the way true
with you this is the mega man battle
network connections collection of games
that came out they're in the ps2 or
gameboy advanced game boy ds era y'all
wouldn't think about that no way and i
mean xbox fans they wouldn't find a
badass norway a lot of people were
aggravated when those games were coming
out back in the day because they came
out in such quick succession like the
turnaround on those games were because
there's a lot of those games that's over
there so the turnaround on them games is
kind of you know it was it was od uh as
the new yorker would say shout out the
red after me bg it it was a little too
much um
by this not coming to xbox yeah look i'm
gonna keep it true with you i don't
really think you're missing nothing if
you're not into that type of game
because this
as you know it's so different right
you attack on it's three different
levels
it's levels to this it's actually three
different levels and this you can attack
on one level you have to evade other
attacks on different levels so you move
back up and down back and forth you can
move i think there's three levels back
and three levels four there's a lot to
it
yeah yeah it's yeah man love them i
don't really think them games
respectfully i don't think those games
were that popular back then they made a
lot of them so they must have sold
somewhere but i just later on
and i feel like those type of games sell
more on game boy let's be real here this
this game is going to cl this game on
switch
is going to eclipse whatever playstation
makes like it's not even going to be
funny the difference in sounds
i
you know what
it did that depends like because a lot
of those games are basically like more
handheld experiences but you said this
game was on um steam as well right on
pc2 yeah
they they only made an xbox and this is
kind of
i don't i don't know i don't know maybe
whoever is the because i know capcom
owns it or whoever you know capcom
probably just had like an internal thing
with them they'll be like well we gave
them
is it chrono cross they gave them one of
those final fantasies that was going on
so we gave you some handy downs okay all
right listen look at you look here's the
thing they're gonna have to see how them
they're going to see like look we're
going to give you what we give you and
if it sell well then i will give you
everything else but if it don't sell
well
don't you waste time i ain't gonna lie i
ain't feeling that energy
hey you know sir these are the facts sir
they they look they don't want to waste
their time in in building something for
that and then pushing it over i feel
them man i wouldn't waste my time even
if y'all know you're not gonna buy the
jordan so usually so do you stand just
alienating
even the few xbox fans that game ain't
hard to port over the xbox man yeah
especially on steam well i got a
question for the both of you okay it
looks like it was made by six people and
yeah man that gave me hard to pull over
the xbox man
i can't say but you can't say no you
know what
i don't wanna you know what i don't care
about xbox fans
i don't care if it's 16 xbox fans that
want to play that crappy game
point it over hey now we're gonna say
it's crappy back we ain't gonna say it's
crazy it's not i don't know yeah look at
it
hustle it was on the game boy
it was on the game boy but that that ds
their numbers though that dsd
playstation 2 number so of course it was
there so of course like that's the
reason why i don't want to do kingdom
hearts games was over there
but to me all right well first off kid
smooth has joined it he don't look like
he's in a good mood at all look at that
heart that means
he'd be
no i'm good um i just want to make sure
my i'm using i'm coming from the right
mic am i coming from a mic or my website
it does sound like you're coming from a
webcam yeah does it really
[ __ ] yeah okay but now
maybe it was too far away from your
mouth i don't know okay but it did sound
like you said a little annoying yeah uh
we got to find out from artemis good
luck good day to the lord seeing my boy
dirt on the show today reminding me to
make sure i have enough charcoal for
barbecue
damn respect sir
this is not wbg
this is iron lord's podcast you sold
some respect
you pos that was that was definitely a
crazy secret
is that how it be rolling with you dirt
yeah man they be roasting me in my chat
man that's cool though like like there's
a difference uh between like roasting
and disrespecting that's clear
it's all fun man if you grew up you know
let me tell you guys something cause you
guys you know you're obviously white and
smooth and hustle you're not really dark
as me but growing up in the black
community as a dark skinned brother i
got those jokes for years you know i'm
thick skinned i can handle
what's crazy it's like just youtube in
general i was reading some comments and
someone on one of my reviews was like
because you know i say at the beginning
of the reason you know if you enjoyed
the video definitely hit that like
button you know it's people's like the
moment people self-promote i just
automatically click off and i'm like oh
so you you you don't you you hate
commercials on tv the moment mcdonald's
has a commercial you just flipping off
the video huh it's like man like i get
it like part like i actually had to have
someone like look dude that's your
platform you can do whatever the hell on
your platform and it's not like i'm
sitting there forcing people to like the
video and like there will be sometimes
i'll be listening to a podcast and
someone say yo hit that like button if
you guys enjoy the the podcast and i
remember i can share it yeah yeah i
remind my oh yeah i do need to like the
the video because people do forget
that's why yeah a lot of people bring it
up so often but all right
we'll back it up a little bit what's
going on smooth
what's you just come from the pool
yeah i actually took a shower um and
um how'd you get that chlorine out you
had to get the chlorine off of me so
that was
that now i'm trying to get out of this
then i pick my background trying to get
out of the screen
um
yeah so no i had um
damn still not good enough
[Music]
anyway no yeah so i went to the pool
with the kids in the morning uh
spent about almost three hours there and
then wanted to at least get in the
shower
um and wipe that off me and i'm like
crap it's ten minutes after let me get
into this podcast um but
thank you uh for having me sorry that
i'm late
i use only like five minutes later if
that
but uh yeah so so what we're talking
about right now is move we're talking
about
the battle network game the the uh the
mega man games uh being not being an
xbox like i know we briefly talked about
on the phone i know you don't really
care about these type of games uh so i'm
sure when you saw that you was like
because you're pretty much on on you
know
respect say you're pretty much online
saying yo keep all your junky ass
japanese games though smooth is on this
like vendetta against japanese games now
like square enix god cat khan don't
don't don't watch out man they're going
to have smooth on them next
i mean it would be nice to have them but
i'm sorry i mean i'm not saying like i
know people accuse me of not keeping the
same energy um
i
i mean mega man is mega man should it be
there yes it's on the switch it's on
playstation 4's on pc it should be able
to be on the xbox i'm not sure what's
really stopping them um from putting it
on xbox but you're not going to hear a
complaint out of me because it's not as
big as a final fantasy so
i i agree with you and it's kind of a
collection but to me
i do feel like this
this is
i don't know
okay let's put the conspiracy hat on all
right
let's let's let's put it on
is it me
like i know people have thrown this
this around but i'm starting to really
believe it is certain people holding
back on xbox on purpose to get that game
pass back later like
i don't know because to me when you look
at something like this
i don't i can't logically find a reason
to hold this back
i mean it's not a publishing though
because it's on it's on it's on
playstation and and steam
uh it was originally on on nintendo
platform so i don't think it's a
publishing deal like
it's just weird that it gives on
everything but this platform and to me
this is the perfect type of game pass
game you know what i'm saying and i'm
just like
i don't i don't know like do you guys
think that something like that might be
happening when it comes to some of these
like smaller titles they're like look
we're not gonna necessarily sell the
best
on xbox when it comes to this so maybe
we'll hold it for a couple weeks or a
couple months
and see if it does up in the back yeah
or what that game passed back i doubt it
for the simple fact that
it's the value the more money you're
going to make from xbox game passes
developer and publisher is if you're
going to be there day one the day and
date but here's the thing that's what's
going to
i feel you on that but what happens if
they're trying to have like that because
obviously right now final fantasy not
come to the platform there's a lot of
pressure on them for the japanese market
ones that they're they're trying to like
low-key put that that pressure on them
too like this is another japanese game
that's not going on your platform
um
yeah but it still doesn't it wouldn't
make sense they got they got two hurdles
to clear you either put it because
there's a ton of japanese games coming
on xbox that aren't coming to game pass
any day like you got soul hackers too
you got this other one that just
appeared on the marketplace i mean
whatnot so like there's games obviously
that they want on like you know in the
service but it's just getting on the
platform mega man didn't have to come to
game pass to be on xbox and if you're
holding out for a game pass back then
the value is going to get
a shorter the bag
the earning potential to get like a game
pass like bonus is going to be smaller
the longer you wait because
to me the game isn't as big and like i
said xbox will pay for shock value oh
this isn't game pads oh day and date the
day and date is if you're gonna if you
want to hold on on day date then don't
announce any platforms show off the game
and then let them come to like okay like
how much to get this on game past day
and date but if you're gonna just sit
there oh i got the time and the resource
to put this on playstation and put this
on steam
it right now it just seems like a
priority issue they're not prioritizing
xbox as a a platform for this game which
is i can see if there's like a new ip or
something like that because this is like
a freaking port
it's a 2d port
if it is a priority issue
then
who do we set that blame on capcom for
not putting the priority or xbox for not
seeking the game capcom and xbox japan
xbox [ __ ] need to seek the game they're
a platform holder nintendo doesn't need
to seek games playstation doesn't need
to seek games those platform exists
developers exist make the game put it on
the platforms that that exists and why
does xbox got to be the only platform
order to shop can we get your game on
that platform playstation doesn't have
man
i feel you but at the same time you you
looking it's not a good look because
this isn't the first game this year
that's the best
platform but xbox but here's the thing
no one cares about who publisher who
developed it they're gonna look on that
what does it come out on it's gonna be
one platform not on that list that's all
they're gonna care about
here's the thing there's no hurdles from
xbox that's keeping games off of xbox i
could if i was
uh smart enough and talented enough to
make a game i could release a game on
xbox today for free
like i'm technically free
so it's like there's no hurdles there's
nothing stopping people from releasing
games on xbox this is just a priority
thing
it's a priority thing and in the fact
that
uh xbox has to shop
to put games on a platform it's like
that that's just that's not realistic
you know what i mean at the end of the
day you're selling you're making a game
you got a game to sell
sony doesn't have to buy the game from
you to set like you have to sell the
game you put it on platforms that have
customers like that doesn't make that
doesn't make sense i like i don't like
developers that operate that way whether
they're from japan china korea or like
america
don't
europe don't don't make games with that
mindset where like you know the the
platform hoarder has to come to me
you're the you have to sell the damn
game sell the game you ain't gonna sell
again to me if you're not on my platform
let me pick you back off your your
points move yeah now they shouldn't have
to go to them but i'm sure that there
were some numbers internally that uh
capcom saw before they was like you know
we're going to put this here we're going
to put this here we're not going to put
this here for this reason they got to be
numbers that they sold because i'm be
real with you i'm looking at because
there's 10 different games for the
people who may not know because i
already thought it was just a handful no
it's 10 different was
when when i said that they released
these games back in the day like
it was like world war ii titles they
were releasing some joys like every
other month every few months and all
that that that's like no that's a no-cap
situation they was releasing these
joints every so often um look i'm gonna
keep it real with you now xbox shouldn't
have to like jump out the window and say
hey now bring this game over here if i'm
capcom i would take it over there
but i guess maybe they feel like it
would just cut into their sales because
it will be on game pass uh that's if
it's even on game because it's not even
on xbox period it's not the fact that
they can ganks i'm thinking the first oh
maybe it's just not in game pass no i
looked at it it's not on xbox at all
which that ain't that ain't cool if i'm
capcom
i'm gonna try to make as much bread as
that off of that as possible just to see
if people still
that's the part that don't make sense to
me hustle
this is this like
you look at certain games like final
fantasy vii remake to a point you're
like okay
this game probably gonna cost a little
in and i'm not gonna say who i talked to
but i did talk to someone when it come
to porting they say you know it's up in
the air but most of the time
it
the the money you get on the back end
justifies the port regardless
there's very few times that that port
port's gonna cost more money than you
would actually get from the sales
so it's just like and i look at
something like this and i'm like
i just that's why i'm like is there some
form of you know
low-key like holding something a game
hostage like because i just don't see a
reason why it's not on the platform i
just can't logically find a reason why
this is not on a platform so you know
so let me say like
maybe this is a game that
is going to come in xbox later maybe a
small team ported this game and they
only had the resources to point it to
playstation
steam and
nintendo at the time and that's the
platforms they chose to do it for
initially
maybe xbox support will come later
that's the only thing i can think of
that's only um legitimate reason
i can think of can only afford three
platforms and not four
listen there's not a big team on these
games supporting these games right now
probably a few people pouring these
games over
and maybe you'll come to xbox a little
bit later this year yeah you know i'm
saying maybe they just had a resource to
support all of the platforms at the same
time that's the only thing i can think
of i mean
at the end of the day i'm playing this
i'm gonna buy for playstation i'm gonna
still play it's just and people what's
funny is i made
what because i ain't well we knew this
game
wasn't
so like i think what
what irritates me the most
is just these smaller titles and what's
funny is like i made a post and i was
like look
go wherever platform is that has the
games you like i got all the platforms
uh i got the play the the big bulky
playstation that i could bench wait over
here i got the xbox i got a pc i'm on a
switch over there
i can play these games but that's not
the point the point is i want
i want the platform that i primarily
game on to be better and so that's why i
made the tweet i was like look like you
know i'm never gonna not say yo i don't
like this is not on xbox i'm always
gonna vocalize that because
i'm prime i feel like if it wasn't for
the people like me that speak out on
stuff like that that want the final
fantasies on that we wouldn't get stuff
like octopath traveler that went into
game pass we wouldn't get stuff like
persona coming out this year because
clearly we're the minority by far like
there ain't a lot of us out there but i
do feel like there is enough people on
the xbox platform that vocalize stuff
that microsoft feels like maybe they
won't make money off of but they feel
like they have to appeal to these people
because there's a lot of them
anyone want to jump on that or are we
done with the japanese talk because i
know you guys don't care what yeah i'll
just uh
i hope this regardless of
the situation i kind of hope this game
does so so people can get a sequel to
its franchise came out what year is this
like this to say it came out like 15
years ago you know it was like the early
it was one of the state was in the early
2000s games like a world war ii
type game and stuff like that so i mean
the the game preservation is in me it's
like cool to see that this stuff is
still living on and i kind of hope it
will continue to live on um yeah put it
on xbox though like yo what do you
because you know i thought this just
wasn't on game pass as i said before but
you don't know it's not on that platform
at all it's not yeah it's not all it's
not xbox at all you don't lose nothing
by putting it there so you just go throw
that joint on there don't let me put in
gamepad just put it on a platform huh
i'm one of those people hustler i look
at something like this and i'm just like
i can understand that game pass i can
understand i'm not in the in the camp
where everything's got to be in game
pass if something's in game pass i feel
like that that's that's a cherry on top
at this point i just want it on my
platform like i don't even care if it's
not in game pass and it would be
different if it was stuff that makes
sense final fantasy rebirth it was it's
bull but it makes sense because i'm
pretty sure playstation has secured the
majority of that final fantasy 7 title
but this that's the only point this
didn't make sense and you know maybe it
is what dirt said maybe they only put a
certain amount of
you know budgeting when it come to this
and they prioritize the other platforms
over this platform uh you know i do
think it will come to the platform
eventually it's just like
i the biggest thing that annoys me is
when i see this sucker on everything
that's that's when i get annoyed but
here's the thing i'ma say this right i'm
not too mad because there's about seven
uh big time japanese games um coming um
to xbox that's available to pre-order
right now in the next uh three to four
months so you got this game called
overrogue which is a duo um uh tuesday
or wednesday
um there's
azure striker gun vault 2 i've never
heard of it but it's definitely a
japanese anime action adventure game i
might give it a try it's 20 bucks
um that comes out the 14th so it's next
week you got capcom arcade stadium 2 so
they're not giving us mega man but they
are giving another collection of bundles
that has a ton of games which includes
mega man by the way mega man is in the
in this bundle um so that comes out uh
july 22nd
you also got
uh sd you have sd gundam battle alliance
which comes out august 25th being
dynamic shout out to them best japanese
publishers uh next to capcom um and sega
um and you've got uh soul hackers two
which is um
coming out august 26th the day after
and this is
um soul hackers is
also by oh this is by sega
um and you got a
jojo's bizarre adventure all-star
uh battle uh
all-star battle r which is coming out
september first is google that that
that's the list that that jojo's
resolving the list
i'm in the xbox store and that's also by
bandai name coke that's the fighting
game right
yeah okay uh you also got the the divine
force
which is coming out the star ocean the
divine force comes out october 27th
i don't i don't feel like
they're not progressing in the support
for japanese that's why i didn't really
put the blame too much on xbox i do feel
like this might be more of a capcom
thing
but it's just like regardless
what the logistics are and regardless of
what the reasoning that this isn't on
xbox it doesn't make it sting any less
you know what i'm saying it still sucks
so that's pretty much all i have on this
topic you know
i i personally
am tired of this stigma
oh that doesn't sell on this platform
well if you never give us the games how
are we supposed to buy them ever
and then if you give us one game and you
skip two other sequels and then you give
us the game five years later
then you did you expect sales like it
was a day one i don't understand that
and i think that's my biggest thing it's
like look like
i get it
playstation people buy a lot of japanese
games so does the switch people it's
like why don't you get put some faith in
the green box man that's all i'm saying
man that's all i'm saying so
smooth
yes and do i sound okay
for saying um
oh oh um yeah my bad my bad
so
my question to you smooth is i saw you
talking about crackdown on
on
on
on twitter
and what's funny i brought this up and
uh dirt was like we talking about
crackdown yes we talking about crackdown
i actually enjoy the crackdown franchise
and i felt like crackdown 3 was a
classic example of over ambition and
they couldn't do what they originally
wanted to so they had to scale back
and i feel like the reason crackdown hit
us the way crackdown hit us is because
we expected a different game so i do
feel like it was un unfairly reviewed if
that makes sense and it wasn't reviewed
off what we got it was reviewed off of
what we were promised if that makes
sense so that makes sense do you guys
feel like we need another crackdown
another shot at this franchise to
to justify the wrongs i do feel like the
multiplayer was was lacking compared to
what we were told yeah multiplayer was
yeah i felt like the campaign was good
like you know
yeah i agree with you really good it was
really good i enjoyed the campaign
matter of fact i'm about to play through
it again with my son um
um but i i don't like i downloaded it on
pc so i could kind of know because they
didn't obviously didn't fps boost it and
whatnot which is a shame that game looks
that game
the best way to play that game
is right now obviously you know at 60
frames or better because the game looks
good it was a good looking game
um the story was dope um it was a lot of
fun i i just boot up the game just to
mess around sometimes especially in the
keys to the city mode where you kind of
could just you could fly and you know
kind of just have access to like every
weapon um i don't think we need to see a
crackdown for it but i do think they
need to show some um reboot love to
crack down one and two
um and just uh
and then you know you can announce a
crackdown for or do some sort of like
i don't know if you want to put a number
next to it but i do i would like to see
something with the crackdown franchise
whether that be um
remake or reboot um crackdown one and
two or you'd uh do a fourth game but i
do agree with you that the game was
unfairly reviewed unfairly criticized uh
the meta score was what a 58 for i don't
know what reason um you can't play the
game crackdown say that this is a bad
game it's better than the first two
games um it was only an upgrade i think
the first it's better than the first two
games the second one was whack and the
second one was trash the second one was
underwhelming because the
the first one was so good for its time
and let's let's let's be honest the
first time the first one we played for
halo 3 dude
i was about to say that but it doesn't
take away that it was still a fun game
it was it was a decent game it was fine
though didn't have a trajectory that
went up like we had like massive up and
downs with the franchise
uh so it's a dirt dirt man
what do you what do you think on the
crackdown you know you didn't feel like
you wanted to talk about crackdown on
this show only because it's not really a
relevant topic but i will say this i
wholeheartedly agree with what you said
though
i agree that it got judged on what we
were promised instead of what we got now
the multiplayer
you know it was fun for exactly like 30
minutes
then it kind of got old real quick but
like you guys said i thought the
campaign was dope the campaign was dope
i enjoyed the campaign like he had a
little story i'm not a deep story of
course but i had a little story had some
cool bosses
decent graphics i enjoyed the campaign
man all the collectibles it was a good
it was a good campaign um
but like you guys said i think you just
got killed because of what we were
promised that initial was that 2015
gamescom that initial um gameplay of the
multiplayer that looked amazing
and we got nothing close
nothing close to that really uh so i
really feel the delays
it was just a multitude of things at
that time smooth knows everybody knows
how rough it was for xbox during those
years
especially 2017 2018
then a rough time to be yeah yeah
absolutely
on youtube for xbox it was a rough time
imagine trying to start a pro xbox
youtube channel during those years uh
you know it was difficult but
so when it was finally delayed to 2019
and people you know it was already
negativity surrounding the game
there was already negativity surrounding
the game so when i played i was like
this campaign is pretty dope
but you know nobody cared a guy with a
59 mega critic a 60 what was the six i
don't know what it was
a 58. it went down to 58 smooth damn
and i feel like that that that game is
not a 58 no i mean it was a good
campaign that campaign was fun
like it was fun man it was fine maybe
it's because they should have centered i
felt like if if they could go back and
redo
what crackdown 3 was it would have been
a completely different game i feel like
they promised that game on the
standpoint of where they thought cloud
computing at that time would be
but it didn't evolve the way they wanted
to i know they had a reset you know
development a couple times
it's just like look at the other day i
feel people when it comes to crackdown
i understand that they never make a
crackdown again i i get it crackdown had
its opportunity and it failed multiple
times i felt some people i did enjoy the
crackdown franchise even too it's just
two was definitely underwhelming
compared to the rest but it's just like
to me
if they make a crackdown first off
spoiler alert they definitely
foreshadowed another crackdown
you can even have smooth at the end of
crackdown for three but it's just like i
don't know if there's enough engagement
there to even
realistically visit that game yeah
even if the game were to be made who
would make it
yeah and you know what i agree with
unfortunately i don't think there's
enough engagement there i don't think i
think the franchise is tarnished
um i think you know it will have to be a
hell of a game
for people to to get interested in the
franchise again it will have to be
absolutely incredible um and i just
don't know
if that's possible what do you think
hustle you you've been over there
talking
did you even play this photo let me let
me get these two super chats yeah you
can get the super chat
before you slander this game because i
feel like you about to slander mm-hmm we
got two dollars from uh dan lorenzo if i
butchered your name i apologize to hell
with them games and playstation oh damn
lazaro the homie what's up man tts you
got a two dollar super chat from
victoria st
uh it needs a reboot like insomnia it
gave to a spiderman i actually feel like
rebooting crackdown would do a lot of
good for it and i do feel like that
could be a pillar of xbox but they got
to put serious money behind it and they
got to actually find a developer to make
the type of game that crackdown needs to
be yeah what do you feel hustle well
hold on answer this question first the
last crack crackdown on three small
digital did correct yes they did that
the campaign they did the campaign
campaign oh okay which was the good part
uh well why i'ma keep it real with you
and that's it's kind of ties in the
smooth and the ties and the bg
them the only two youtubers so i saw
like even playing that game online
smoove had tried like the resurrecting
multiplayer sadly it's a normal
i'll keep a trail with you dog like so
when i saw crackdown for the first time
and i know i had the halo 3 and i was in
the halo super heavy back then i said
nah this just it didn't hit for me i
didn't know about the whole
you know when you shot a wall it had so
many different like characteristics
for the original crack there i ain't
know about none of that i just you know
just wanted to try hello three and all
that i just didn't enjoy it then you
know and when crackdown three dropped
i'm like now i'm good
dude and i'm good i'm good on that
microsoft they need to keep that in the
drafts it's for as long as possible they
don't need to bring that joint back at
all though cause like they don't really
add nothing
for me
it just just for me just for me like now
i just this is just one and i'll try
whatever but like now it's just
something about that one that just
didn't particularly hit right they can
keep that website um if y'all have fun
with it you know continue to have fun
with it
but now that that wasn't that chief it
ran well it ran well from what i was in
like that that was cool you know that it
ran super well at 1440p and there wasn't
any uh any issues regardless of whatever
that
metacritic score was you know it doesn't
matter but like for me
i'm cool and it's this and this is like
the hustle formula right like i like
third person action adventure games like
i think this is a different type of
third person like
yeah i think the problem hustle
is they were so laser focused on that
multiplayer
the the campaign was an afterthought and
after they realized they couldn't do
that multiplayer they wanted to i feel
like they scrambled for the campaign
and
the campaign was good but imagine if
they would have took all that time that
they were trying to make that
multiplayer work and dedicated it all to
a single player
driven story that you're a superhero
growing in strength
from city to city and then like you had
like kind of like i think the problem is
that instead of having that everything's
destructible way they should have had
just a gta 5 multiplayer where people
could just cause havoc because i was
trolling smooth as mike as my agent on
his his character imagine if you do that
with like 20 people
but you know they went for a very
ambitious
thing and i think it blew up for the man
i i really do
yeah
all right so let's let's talk about one
of the uh
let's talk about one of the the smoke
man
we could talk about the japanese uh xbox
selling well or we could talk about god
of war uh but i do think we're we're
going to say the god of war for last
because i feel like
there's so much to that topic it's
unreal
and i i want to really go over because
we got like kind of two uh bulletin
points for god war but i do want to talk
about halo real quick uh it does look
like there is a i saw people on twitter
talking about there is a campaign uh
i guess they're in the insider program
they're having that in there uh so you
know and then you know i want to know
where forge is like
i actually feel like
halo infinite needs that that campaign
that co-op campaign but i feel like the
game
needs forge more right now
and that's where i want to just go
around the table you know first off
we'll talk about
to you where is halo right now
uh then we'll talk about you know the
campaign if you think that's relevant
then we'll talk about you know whether
or not you think that fords would be a
better you know focus at currently right
now so
we'll start with you you know and what's
funny is
everyone here has played a good amount
of halo like even hustle like i know
huss will be hating on the the the xbox
brand sometimes but you know he's played
a lot of this game too so you know i'm
kind of curious where's halo to you
right now hustle
six feet on the ground jordan's dead
i can't curse away i joined super dead
dog um
it's dead it's over what get it out of
it sir who is that dirk there's me it's
dead
zombies how quick are you how quick are
you finding game on hello if it's there
you can't find the game right it's over
it's over come on you know what kell
hello infinite 343 sorry three four
three killed there
all right i'm gonna take it anyway with
the recent juneteenth actions of three
four three i never picked that joiner
began with the recent like
those actions like the limited game
modes whatever i got like 55 out of 60
hours in that joint man like
i'm good homie i'm good on the whole
joint the joint it's over it's over it
it is it is over they yeah they got a
beta this month or july in july like the
middle part of july for like the co-op
online and all that i'm good i'm good
love and joy uh i promise i'm fine on it
and the sad part was that game was super
fun it's fun it wasn't it wasn't a bad
game whatsoever but they chose not to
add content
they could have delayed they probably
should have delayed it another a whole
another year in my
humble opinion i could have delayed that
joint again man just to make sure
everything was right i chose to rush it
out
and then take dates like that yo listen
the fact that it was delayed a year from
its original release date and it's still
like not that they underperformed in
terms of gameplay just under performed
in terms of content no i'm good and then
like with the recent stuff i'm good i'm
good though
talks this uh this chaotic stuff i'm
going to give it to dirt uh later uh
look search for a game on halo infinite
see how long it takes you to find a game
on uh on non-ranked matches search for a
game and count it down for us and hold
up first off let's let's determine
what's dead what is dead dirt
you got to look for like two minutes
down three multiplayers there try to
find a game on there
so okay chat what do you consider dead
what do you consider the point where
there's no return that game isn't being
resuscitated like it is officially done
how many minutes before because i do
feel like even if you find a game
that doesn't mean that the game isn't
dead but i i do feel like if you're
spending five plus minutes that's
probably dead but let's see go uh you
know go to regular uh halo that's the
majority of people playing and tell tell
me how long it takes you to find the
game so someone said three minutes the
game is booting up so yeah
um
you know why he looks up there and we
prove hustle wrong live
i'm i'm i'm gonna defend myself too go
yeah go ahead smooth i'm gonna defend
myself on this too but y'all go ahead
i'm gonna put a timer from when i hit
the um yeah and show us your phone why
does it like when you're timer
a good question what makes a game dead
is this a deck is it subjective
is it what what makes the game dead to
me my opinion a multiplayer game is dead
if you log on
sorry my bad what mode do i need to
select just do slayer that's where
everyone plays slightly all right do it
so quick play yeah quick place layer
all right
all right so continue dirt so like i
said like if if in my opinion if a game
is dead
there's no engagement nobody's playing
the damn game
like i said the example i said crackdown
3 that multiplayer is dead try fighting
the game last year i tried to play that
game i didn't find a game at all
dead
was the last time you tried to play
crackdown
it was i think it was september 2021 i
said let me play this right quick
nothing
couldn't find
[Laughter]
halo infinite is still getting
content you know i know it's not as fast
as we would like but it's still getting
right match begins in three
two
one oh let me stop it under
under what's that second 150 seconds is
that dead to you their hustle is that
they have to take into
there is stuff we have to take into
consideration that was taking out the uh
the the amount of time it took to
actually load the lobby it didn't even
take that long because if you look the
moment
they say found match loading in that is
when you actually end it because that's
when the networking part is has took off
and they're actually loading the game
that has nothing to do with the people
actually going on there so in all sense
like 30 seconds 30 seconds it took to
load that game does that sound like a
dead game to me that's definitely not a
dead game
all right all right all right listen
here bots uh look it could be dead to
you it could be dead to you no no no no
in terms of like yo everything that
there is to doing that game has already
been done
and that's what i mean by dead like yo
it ain't nothing new though is this
coming from a guy that love playstation
single player game
no no no hustle hold on hold on 1990
first of
yeah but don't get the twister man don't
get twisted i like all of it i like all
of it
but still good at this this is but this
this is halo this is this is halo this
is xbox's mario like the fact that it
came out like this
it ain't cool though cause nintendo will
never let mar let this happen to mario
and to the homeboy in the chat he know
who he is yo the next time you call me
on my name you're definitely getting
blocked you better chill
yeah yeah yeah like relax homie but no
no no like
for me though is the content it was the
juneteenth thing yes it did bother me
because the half-assed apology from
bonnie ross i wasn't cool to me though
so i'm like and i'm gonna put bread
behind that too like i just spent money
behind that so i'm like nah so for you
to view me a certain way
and for just to be ignored for me i'm
like nah so like let's go on that you
know yeah the way they're handling stuff
in that matter
yeah said nobody said they're perfect
i'm strictly going by you said the game
is dead
that's what i'm going by well okay you
said it was six feet okay
there you go okay let me let me say
there that hustle yeah you can go on the
final whatever it's over this the
numbers on that game kind of
whatever those numbers are okay
you're right hey on pc smooth where do i
play though
thank you sir i don't have an xbox
series x just yet it's only because i
can't really find one to get one but i
don't have that yet and plus i'm not
trying to pay for the online but on pc
it's you know it is what it is and the
game is fine also they're sweating
sweating
my air conditioning is on i'm i'm good
i'm straight i ain't worried about that
and i ain't worried about nobody
chatting either
yeah that's just how i felt though but
now after that whole the gym same thing
with me man because i really wanted to
play the um
the online um the multiplayer co-op for
the uh myself play club the um
the campaign co-op i really wanted to
run that with a shout out to contra and
uh mega i really wanted to run that with
him because we did that with halo reach
but it just
that whole thing just left a bad taste
in my mouth so when i say it's dead let
me let me reiterate it's dead to me okay
that's that's why i'm saying fine
brother that's one percent fine hey it's
a thousand percent fine if i say it's
dead on it
if that joint dead on the table it's so
it's over but now you know it's just one
of those things like and it is actually
a sad thing to see that halo kind of
fell as far as it did because like again
this is
yo this is halo this is xbox's mario
though like
no no other company would have let this
happen
like you said i'm saying nintendo
wouldn't let this happen when mario was
what i'm trying to say
i will say that hold up hold up hold up
hold up
explain smoove
let me know
the wii u flap flop crazily that's
that's the reason why it it exists
the switch exists
but we'll drop that to oh because we can
have that conversation too when when
the because it happened with the
gamecube as well right but what happened
with the gamecube at launch they didn't
launch me on mario
huh gamecube was sick there was nothing
wrong with the gamecube i mean
it underperformed i like the gamecube
too don't get the [ __ ] up pardon me
don't get it twisted don't get twisted
but
what was what what was the the key
determining factors with that i don't
know about the wii u in particular but i
don't think getting lost with a mario
game i don't know about i know for a
fact the gamecube that launched with the
mario game and lots of like luigi's
mansion and all that what am i trying to
play is luigi you understand what i'm
saying like so there's there's there's a
caveat to that so
johnson said ask battlefield developers
of hey lewistown
that's it hey that's a very good point i
forgot they said that thanks
i don't know
listen after at the end of the day my
personal opinion
halo infinite release without
some modes that we wanted yes and and
and getting the content is is taking
longer than we want but
i will say this the game release
polished
the game release pilots like you said
axe dice because that's that's exactly
what they said halo infinite release
polish the campaign i love the campaign
um i love the multiplayer yes do we want
more content absolutely do we want fours
do we want um um
co-op campaign absolutely and that's
things that should have been there at
launch
unfortunately they wasn't but
they have this road map uh you know
clearly halo with uh anthony is a games
as a service that's not an excuse
but
my thing is
i think the game is not that i was
playing playing it last night it's still
fun it's still a lot of fun um and i'm
still having fun with the game so yeah i
mean you know this your opinion hustle
of course
but i'll just
oh man
still be
looking let's see
as we ask me on the podcast right now
look at this so
here here's here's what i think all
right
i do feel like halo
is in a bad state but i don't think it's
dead i think the gameplay carries it
over that dead threshold
um this game did come out and it did
what it needed to do in terms of the
gameplay was where it was everything
else just it wasn't where it was now
look does that mean they're going to be
able to turn the franchise around and
turn halo infinite around no
uh but i do feel like
there was an incident where
they were too ambitious early on in
development and by the time they really
figured out where they wanted it to go
with the franchise they were so far
behind and they probably would have
caught up to a point but then covet hit
and they even pushed them even further
back i agree with you on that yeah i do
feel like
we're seeing
still
the old halo infinite the halo infinite
before
uh what's his name came and took over um
joseph stanson joseph state i think he's
had
minor stuff he could change in that time
frame but i don't think him being in
charge could do enough significance
to change anything in that time frame i
do feel like probably in the next six
months two years you're gonna start
seeing his vision of how the halo
multiplayer should have been his vision
and how the campaign should have been
there was a lot of you know i want to
briefly talk about this real quick there
was a lot of you know rumors going
around about where
the next campaign was going to be and it
said it was going to be like 2024 or
something like that and like next year
the battle royale was going to come out
so you know smooth i i i want i want you
to briefly go over what
if this game came out if we got another
campaign in 2024
would that disappoint you if it was
a huge amount of content and it was
worth the wait would you be okay with
that if they pushed it back to 2024
i would be disappointed if their the
next campaign uh was a 2024 release i
think that would be stupid um i would be
extremely disappointed because at the
end of the day it's like um
your plan is to turn this thing into
i just don't like that a lot of i feel
like a lot of this game is being broken
up into like seasons when a lot of stuff
should have been delivered like day one
like the co-op to forge and stuff like
that shouldn't really be a seasonal
thing that should be a part of the
initial package
um
so the thing is i really like the
campaign so i would be my disappointment
would be different because i actually
want to dwelve into more of the halo
campaign now it looks like this co-op is
about to happen so i'm going to play it
again through co-op
um but i really want to i want to see
what else they come up with
within this campaign like are they going
to bring us to different bottoms and
stuff i don't think we need to wait
with halo infinite released in 2021 i
think it should be a three-year wait for
something like that
um
so i would be disappointed if that's the
next time we got a piece of a halo
campaign ones if the
let's say they do have a huge amount of
content that comes out in 2024 and it
and it's free do you think that makes up
for a little bit or do you think
if they tr if they have a good amount
where you know it shows
uh the events that happen at the end of
halo infinite they carry on
and they put like they put like 40 bucks
behind that do you think that's gonna
that's gonna sour people
um
[Music]
i don't know
like once i think once it gets here
right i feel like if it gets here people
will ultimately
be um
happy especially if it's good right
but
they gotta
between now and let's say that dates
true right between now and then they
have to like do a lot to make up for and
be in that time to make us not feel like
dude this is just a waste of time and
effort you know what i mean so i feel
like they're the next couple seasons
have to be epic when they have to
shorten these damn seasons because six
months yeah it's kind of like agree
insane ridiculous man
to like try to normalize six months
for seasons i feel like these guys
probably have the best benefits package
ever
like like at 343 the way that they work
they have like uh what you call uh
uh they have like emotional days they
have mental uh
uh mental uh disorder days they have all
these days where they're not working i
hear more about their
mental effort that i do about their
progress on the game but um i fly if
they if they manage to knock it out the
park shorten their seasons
uh deliver what was promised years ago
on this game and and feed us some
quality content
and and between that time and when 2024
you know gets here and they decide to
release a campaign expansion
i think they will be in good shape but
at the way that the rate that they work
i'm not exactly sure what they can do
you know i think it's like what like
what alex said i think they
are behind man um unfortunately because
like you said i agree with what you said
they were doing doing how they uh you
know they were developing the game
they
really their vision was too big they had
to start over
you know i don't know if they changed
engines we heard that they changed
engines or whatever
then
you know then after all of them already
been behind it then kovit hit
you know made him even more behind so
yes i agree smooth they need to know six
months is a little bit too long
um they need to somehow fix that but
hopefully man they can catch up
eventually i mean i i'm not making
excuses because these are real issues
here hopefully they can catch up and
start dropping content more regularly
and i agree the campaign expansion
whatever it is
if it drops in 2024 it better be a nice
10 to 15 hour campaign expansion bro
that's what i was about to say yeah okay
let's
let's say that they always envisioned
halo infinite to be the platform and the
content to go into the game like an
evolving world
and when you get this
halo infinite campaign
it's pretty much gonna be
a full-blown campaign like it's not just
like a small thing not like five hours
like it's a full-blown campaign like
they developed a whole new campaign
would you guys be more okay with that
i would i would if it's like you said a
full campaign like a 10 to 15 hour
campaign absolutely what about you smith
um yeah i mean i'm i'm i'll take any
freaking campaign from them at this
point so i don't have a requirement that
it needs to be
you know a certain amount of hours i
mean i think a good honestly eight to
ten hours is fine with me
what about you hustle
you you've
i don't know maybe you shouldn't talk
about it
i don't care i see what's going on in
the chat and i'm gonna respond to one of
them super chats in a minute it's over
for me let me just say for me it's over
i didn't think i would have to clarify
but you know
yeah for me and i've got a problem
clarify it's open for me
it's over all right so let's go ahead
and get these super chats we'll move on
to the next flight what super chat did
you want to address
uh with my man at
um apollo cooper can go with that all
right let let me get to him and i'll let
you read that
all right so we got a two dollars per
shot from greek head 188
he's saying halo 2 is better than all
jrpgs
yeah final fantasy 7 a pretty big game
man it's a pretty big game persona
all right so then we got uh i did read
the day in lorenzo to uh two dollars to
help with playstation and games
then we got a stroller screwdriver from
victor alastain that needs a spider-man
i said that too i must have missed that
super chat i don't know how i did that
got a two hours from carlos uh avado uh
probably
verrado the coalition needs to make a
good four-player co-op crackdown i don't
want coalition touch and crackdown no i
don't feel like that's the right studio
i'd like coalition to make a punisher
game though that would be nice yeah
that'll be fire i got a
two dollar super chat from united 27
sincerely hope halo doesn't end up like
crackdown
oh my god don't ever
cracked out in the same sentence no i
definitely end up
i enjoyed the crackdown 3 as a crackdown
game some games are judged poorly
because they are
from microsoft sadly hope they make a
four i agree with you i do feel like
some games are uh judged a little bit
differently because they're my microsoft
but i think we're getting a little bit
better on that i feel like yeah i feel
like
playstations actually getting their
games are getting judged on a higher
scale now
but we'll go into that later uh then we
got a two dollar spiritual from uh
carlos
uh probably i'm gonna butcher your name
again man
ava aliviko what was it what was it
hello's alvarado alvarado my bad dude
this
is a
who plays every night it's not dead
uh so look
we we just we just live proved hustle's
uh definition of dead is a little
lacking a little lacking that's fine uh
so then we got to find out the superchat
from don otaku forge dropping in
september will turn halo into a
streaming experience it will surprise it
will surpass its launch numbers by the
end of the year i'm 90 right i do agree
with you and i meant to go over a little
bit on uh forge but i do think we'll
wait a little bit more for information
on that i do feel like forge right now
is more important to get in there than
the co-op experience of uh of the halo
storyline but that's just me uh then we
got a two dollars from dan lorenzo
hustle tripping
it's all good
i appreciate you take it take it man
take it uh he he
there's your super chat all right apollo
cooper thank you for your five dollar
super chat uh my play on pc it took me
17 seconds to blah blah blah blah
let's see
okay hold on hold on hold on we got to
read it that you could leave your
controller
find out who's there for paul
it took me 70 seconds to find a match on
infinite far as gamecube it is
underperformed why is it increased in
the value over later years now what what
what do you can explain that i cannot
explain it
first of all it probably ain't too many
of these left out in a while right and
nintendo games
you know we joke about it but nintendo
games do hold their value if i was to
trade this in right now i pay like 100
for this if i was to really trade this
in back now what the f to the store i
got it from i'd probably get 90 for this
it would it would be a steep discount
but nintendo games yes they hold their
value kirby's what was that one of the
kirby anniversary collections on
nintendo wii the golden price for that
joint is like 200
this is what kirby's well with all the
kirby games on it up until like uh air
ride or something
all of those that that that nintendo
stuff holds their value the reason why
microsoft games are so cheap and it's
not to do the fun fact or lack of their
fun fact it's cause you can get them on
pc
like the uh if you if you're collecting
for xbox right now is super cheap
because a lot of those games are
available on different platforms you can
play them on your xbox og xbox you play
them on your 360 xbox one et cetera et
cetera and steam now and steam too um
you can get halo 1 for like five dollars
because it's everywhere now so like it's
not it's not hard to come by these and a
lot of these you know as y'all know with
the retro stuff a lot of it ain't being
made so when you have a game like super
smash brothers melee or
not even mario sunshine
there is their house so you just got the
case
[Laughter]
don't do that don't you dare
anyway
what's up i was just gonna say well hold
on hold on i was just gonna say if
you're collecting for the og xbox it's
cool to do it now because you can find
all of those games but basically next to
nothing like sure you may have some
outliers like conquers bad further or
conquers further reloaded or conquered
or whatever it's called because they're
not making that anymore and i don't
think they ever re-released that game i
might be wrong but they they've never
re-released that game so like you got
some outliers but like a lot of those
xbox games you can get fulfilled on the
cheap
hey man we gotta follow super parky
shinny wow halo's dead i guess they
should just pack their bags xbox should
do the same too many phil still making
on last of us two multiplayer
i like it just hits you in the gut he
you know those anime fights where
someone gets hit so hard their eyes
start going white that's what just
happened to us
ah yeah right but i'll hold on to that
and i'll see you on september 2nd for
the last of us agreement how about that
is it is it is it
yeah is it coming
oh wow
they took the multiplayer away well it
raised it another day they're making you
pay more money for less content
and smooth you know that damn game fight
don't do that yeah i didn't saw you
playing beat that game on ground this
year i love the last of us i absolutely
love that i ain't playing it for 70
bucks i'm gonna wait till it come to pc
and then
yo hold on let's talk about that real
quick
okay why are y'all tripping off that
when y'all know that game gonna go on
sale in like two or three months
why are you tripping on halo when we
know we can look at content in six to
six months
that's a good way that's because three
four three got management issues they
got to take care of that's probably
maybe i didn't know you like that right
but they they got issues over there they
got they gotta take care of mysteries
that's all that's all all right we're
gonna keep reading these super chats
while hustle breathes from that punch to
the gut we got a five dollar spread from
lady fox fire halo is dead for me they
have to pull off a miracle to have me
come back three four three months i
don't know what they are doing with the
franchise sad to see shout out to the
lady
what do people want right because i've i
still come up in a situation where
every halo game that i've played like
hit with multiplayer wise halo 3 4 uh
reach
five
um
what was it that kept you playing like
the modes are still there right
you know what i mean i'm sure those
games have more maps and whatnot but the
thing is
i i don't know maybe everybody has
converted to seasonal players i'm not a
seasonal gamer like i play when i play
halo infinite i just play i play to get
my my my rocks off for the like you know
how many hours i'm going to play and
then i'm i'm done i don't i don't play
for a purpose or a goal there now i do
wish they had the classic ranking system
but i don't play for
season pass items or p season pass perks
so i guess like that's why the game
isn't dead for me like i can just pick
it up and me and my son we literally
play i play halo infinite at least once
a day
and it's not because i think it had like
all this content it's just that the
gameplay is the gameplay uh i like to
like feel good about myself when beating
people online and it is what it is but
i'm just curious is it because it's just
that argument that people were like oh
this they're taking too long with their
seasons and all that stuff because this
is the first halo that has
seasons everything else was just
static stat whatever you got is what you
got and they'll update you know with
modes and some you know some seasonal
themes like you know during the holidays
they'll throw like a fiesta in there or
something like that and whatnot but
everything else was
pretty much classic like the if you load
up halo 5 now right the halo we've been
playing for about five years most most
some of us have been playing for five
years
launch is still what's there now
i think the issue smooth and
is because you you might not do this
model
but the whole gaming infrastructure is
built on this model now
like what just because you yourself
don't like the spot on you don't really
play for insignious like cosmetics and
stuff like have you wouldn't looked at
some of the cosmetics for the halo
battle pass
it's it's bad like that there needs to
be more incentive to doing that battle
pass now is it the worst thing in the
world no
i do think there are others i've been
wearing the same costume for about uh
for about a year inhale infinite you've
what i've been wearing the same costume
that's an issue though
for a year you've been playing a game
that is built on how you like
okay okay
hold up for a year you've been playing
playing a game that is built on how you
look because let's be real here uh halo
3 heavily customized customizable halo 5
halo heavily customizable and i feel
like when it comes to this game they
give you a lot of options but they hide
some of the better stuff behind a pay
wall and the stuff in the battle pass
that the stuff in the paywall should be
in they don't have that either like on
destiny
huh next i blame a couple of things for
you know halo's
demise i believe pc gamers in that place
because it is it's microsoft like
addiction with pleasing these guys um
and they ruin the games like pc gamers
are worried that console gamers are
gonna ruin the platform by bringing
console games to pc and you know we are
getting like you know there's things
about console games that pc players
don't like there's things about pc games
and gamers i don't like that's [ __ ]
up my bad that's messing with
my experience like you know what i mean
if halo was an xbox console exclusive
and didn't have to worry about being
free to play it would have been a
perfect 10 out of 10 sort of game nobody
would have any complaints but no they
got
a piece to these dudes in their play
time their play styles how [ __ ] works
how it runs on a certain storefront all
this unnecessary garbage that they're
taking resources to please them i'm
losing out
and i agree with you but what i will say
is
the customization i think needs to be
addressed you shouldn't especially
colors like you have to literally grind
to have colors of a star yeah i think
that's stupid and i think that's
ridiculous like the difference between
halo infinite and something like destiny
is like destiny you could still do
the um
you can still get the cosmetics that you
want you just gotta wait now obviously i
don't know if they're gonna do that
eventually with halo but destiny has a
currency an in-game currency that you
could buy cosmetics called bright dust
sure during the season usually the stuff
that they're launching in that season
you can only buy with real money but
after that season when all the new hot
stuff comes out guests will start
showing up in that store with bright
dust this stuff from the past seasons
and i think halo desperately needs
something like that they need something
where you can grind in game to get a
currency in game that can give you stuff
from past seasons where
it kind of gives people both of both
worlds it's like look like we don't want
to give you the best stuff now because
that's going to be the hot stuff that's
where we're going to make a lot of our
micro transaction money but this old
stuff
will let you work for that in-game and i
think they need something like that well
let's get to the super chats we're going
to keep going back and forth uh all day
on this i've already lost place for
smooth went on his rant give me one
second guys
all right so we got a
no oh that's where
okay right here we've got a five-star
taco we've got a five dollar superstar
from dog nataki 343 he's trying to
support a live service game with half
the staff of bungie and four times less
than the people working on the game uh
that then recent call of duty and war
zone i agree with you people feel like
these games as a service is easy to do
they're not they take a lot of people
got a 10 dollar switcher from dragon
heart yo tv
dragon
yo that's my boy hashtag peace love life
to everyone happy birthday to king david
much love to
fly mastered dirt uh dirt griggity his
greatness hustle what's up attic why
don't i get like a crazy name why does
everyone get master dirk griggity and
then
and then king david gets a gets a happy
birthday and he's like oh what's up
addict like
i'm just joking with you
shout out to dragon huh man that's a
homie i've known that man for quite some
time i think i found him through like
since then them but now he's always been
like an extremely supportive individual
absolutely man great dude man great dude
you know what you know what's true when
when everybody has like when you hear
from different people but everybody got
the same thing to say about you guys
yeah man you know how true man yep
he's been a supporter iop for a while
everyone
if you if you're watching the show man
after the show during the show go over
there and tweet king david what's up my
happy birthday man wish him a happy
birthday we got a member chat from [ __ ]
j
he's been chicken chicken 12 months i
have 22
days played in halo infinite love the
game well does it seem like a dead game
to me
no no no listen listen listen i'm gonna
keep it troubled that game is fun i just
i meant the content wasn't there like
and here's the thing if they were to
have forge there from they want somebody
in the chat said it but i said this on a
previous episode of the attic show
bruh the fans would have put all that
stuff that's missing in the joint
already they would have put it in there
like it would have just given you enough
time to like
look hey
most game
most games they have dedicated fan bases
y'all know somebody would have put some
something in that joint y'all know they
would have put enough content in there
to be like yo take as much time they
aren't paying interns but they did they
thing
we know this yeah yeah of course
all right so we got a two dollars from
phantom kraken they've been trying to
kill halo for 20 years my wbg brother
what's up man
they have been saying that this is the
halo the halo killer yeah
two dollars super chat from dollar to
taco you can get conker live and reload
it on backwards compatible right now
yeah so okay so i didn't know that but
can you get it on pc though because i
don't have no xbox just yet
i'm not sure
guys the xbox series s is one of the
best
emulators
on the market right now all right wait
wait smooth i heard you can't do that no
more though because there's a developer
mode for that right i heard you can't do
that no i thought they stopped you i
said i thought they stopped i wasn't
sure you could still do it it was like
receipts shelby where are you talking
about
god you gotta say uh you got eight
dollars from tyson bojol man i'm sorry
if i butchered your name i mean you guys
know it by now i think you guys change
your names just to mess with me
sometimes halo isn't dead that would be
kill zone ghost fukushima legends the
last of us factions oh and every other
multiplayer sony makes how you feel
about that who is
tyson
we're gonna have to check
hustle man after this i really recommend
you go get your gut checked man this one
might go bust the douglas on i'll
guarantee you right now if i hooked up
the ps4 yes i'm right if i hook up this
ps4 with the last of us remastered and
just hop on and just say turn on last of
us why don't you just wait for the last
of us remake to play i am i am i am but
my point is i can cut that game on right
here
people on my twitter
i can cut that game on right now i have
like 50 people in my chat and now i've
got a thousand followers on twitch this
is how dedicated that fanbase is
hustle just said something i want to
talk about he said that shows how
dedicated that fan base is for factions
it's unfortunate that playstation did
them like that
you got people looking through walls and
everything else
i'm sure whenever it like comes out it's
gonna be fire though
from dawn to talker haley gonna have
more hype and section than last of us
slow down slow down slow down yo this is
not liking this chat right now
so i want you to read that i ain't read
it yet but he added jesus let's see
how get your knee shout out to you sir
um
wait
there was a temporary glitch that
disabled devmo okay thank you oh let's
see but it was fixed immediately um you
can still ah okay okay you gotta sing
the winky face too he winking at you he
winking at you well you know
then we got a two dollars from flame
infinite has less players
20 42 big oh
hey you missed my attic
um
legion for the with two dollars why is
halo master chief collection better than
halo infinity you know what maybe i
should have got more confidence
got more content there's nothing to talk
about
yes uh erica hustle's taking a lot of
l's today in the chat hey erica shut up
wayne we need that input um let's take a
wrench away take a wrench away hey um
real quick though they're apparently i
don't know how true this is but i heard
that they were going to try to add micro
transactions to the halo massive
collection is that true at all that's
what the rumor is that's what the rumor
is
how long is this cosmetic i can care
less bro
right now they have a
like a mini
master chief that goes on your back from
fall guys or something like that
oh yeah before i got yeah oh god oh
paula cooper with the 2.60 chat i'm not
paying seventy dollars to see jose's
boat
rematch
hey hey can i say somebody chris hart
stop lying saying that the destruction
all stars has more people online than
halo anybody stop it just stop it bro
it's jealous
i stop it all right so
let's talk about the state of xbox
you know what dirk i've been telling a
lot
xbox got no games they do yeah how they
keep selling so well if they got no
games hey that's a good question man
listen listen as an xbox fan i will
wholeheartedly i would admit easily
2022 is dry when it comes to first party
triple a games absolutely i cannot fan
boy that like sometimes they're still
selling somehow they're still selling no
now let me say this in the pre-show
hustle says something i wanted to talk
about for a second
when you brought up xbox sales in japan
the first thing hustle said was
shortages
okay standard go-to for a playstation
fan stay right now now now let me say
this
okay we know there's been some shortages
with the playstation 5 absolutely
has that helped xbox a little absolutely
but we're talking about japan
there were times last generation that
xbox one sold 18 consoles an entire
month
my point of saying that is it doesn't
matter
they really didn't rock out with xbox
last generation meaning
they're not going to just buy your xbox
because playstations are not available
they are buying those xboxes over there
because they want them that's the only
thing i'm going to say about that
um we've heard that people said they
should separate the xbox series x and
that's
they have over there
i know both of them is that so
right
i know last week the playstation one but
it wasn't by much yeah i was buying a
couple hundred yeah it wasn't by much so
my point is that for whatever reason the
xbox consoles are selling
for what like well for xbox over there
and they beat playstation the last four
out of five weeks over there so that's
something we have to i'm not sure what
xbox has done to change the mindset of
these um these consumers they have doing
something maybe the xbox series s the
xbox series x they're both selling
good for xbox in japan right now and
hell in the states also
all right so before i give it to hustle
i want i want christopher all the
playstation fanboys you know put your
hands in the air give all the energy to
hustle he's got to make the spirit bomb
man he's got to make the spirit don't
need no help
i don't got no help
yeah yeah thank you for that um didn't
microsoft or didn't he didn't microsoft
didn't they do something where they have
like the majority for like the chips and
for the consoles or something like that
yes they did pay for prioritizing their
yeah of course what you what's your
favorite sony could have done the same
thing no no i was gonna say that i said
i was gonna say which is fine that's
been this that's what you're supposed to
do you do whatever you know ain't no
rules in war well i'm saying boy ain't
no rules in this business thing so you
do what you got to do to get where you
got to go i'm not mad at the fact that
xbox is self-selling playstation man if
i may be more upset at the fact that
xbox is outside on playstation will
really have they lost any exclusives
this year i want y'all to correct me if
i'm not no no no
right so they ain't really launched
nothing this year like i'm i'm probably
more upset at that but now i'm i'm just
cool to see that this whole thing is
like healthy and see i bet you i thought
that i was going to pick it sad and be
the whole playstation to be a pony or
whatever
the chats
the chance to be hustle to submission
you don't want no more smoke
no no no no no no
[Applause]
this is cool that xbox is actually
selling in japan and this kind of brings
us back to the very first topic that we
spoke about how mega man on the battle
network collection was collection over
10 games how was that on xbox and it's
doing when xbox is probably doing well
xbox is outperforming people it's doing
better than they usually do
don't worry about it so like it doesn't
kind of make any sense on why you
wouldn't have that over there but if i'm
if i'm any japanese developer like
you gotta kind of like at least take
this into consideration now you got at
least just look at it like all right
historically they don't do well over
there and i know dirk they
they was down the single digit number
bro it was bad it was bad last
generation it's pretty it's pretty bad
depending on what number you looked at
um my whole thing is it's cool like i i
like the evolution and growth of what
xbox is doing yo phil spencer like
turned the xbox one around like i always
say like yeah you know he turned that
[ __ ] around and
i always i point to the coalition first
like the coalition had um xbox one on
their back last generation you know but
now phil spencer dig out of everything
that went wrong with the xbox one he he
you know he turned that ship around
which is a hard thing to do and and it's
taking time to do it still today it's
taking time
yeah and it's going to probably take a
lot more time to be completely honest
with you yeah yeah
it's going to take some time but no it's
cool to see that that you know things
are moving in a more positive direction
over there man if
i'll say whatever kojima's doing you got
going to wait for that one but whatever
kajim is doing with the cloud
infrastructure i hope i hope it really i
don't even like hideo kojima but i hope
for the fan sakes in japan i hope it
does well so we can just have a little
bit more competition in that marketplace
man like it it'd be cool if there were
way more confidence like look i can go
to uncharted i can go to the last of us
xbox sadly still didn't have something
like that in my opinion on that level
with john hungary
yeah yeah
i agree with you bro
but whatever this new indiana jones game
is right i hope it's something like
uncharted hellblade 2 or something maybe
that might be like a nice third person
action game yeah yeah and that's and
that's just for my preference but now
it's cool to see that they they really
out there doing numbers like that in
japan because they don't
like at all like they've never like
japanese gamers have never really
enjoyed xbox at all like and one of the
reasons take it back to the og xbox one
of the reasons why it sold over there
was because the dead or alive i think it
was like the dead or alive ultimate
edition or something that's one of the
reasons why i sold they said the
controller was too big so they made a
smaller controller like
and which which was a smart move by the
way because the duke is god-awful
the duke was like to me it was like the
gamecube controller in terms of yeah it
was cool for microsoft first party games
but
nothing outside of that for me but not
it's cool to see that that is is doing
what it's doing man but oh as far as the
chat
hey shut up
shut up ain't nobody on my back i don't
you know i'll be trying to keep like a
level-headed like take on all this
always try i always do my best right i'm
not gonna sit up here and just be wrong
for the sake of being wrong and just
disagree with people for the sake of
disagree i'm cool with with everybody in
the chat just keep it respectful with me
and i i got love for y'all i like i like
that whole little back and forth i'm
about to be on your ass in a minute
though but you know i see people sitting
there in my chest too what's up hey can
i say sorry quick like some things in
the chat i mean some people inside
they're making some great points
like playstation i always say this
playstation
makes the best
third person action adventure games
hands down right hands down um so you
mentioned uh
hustle you mentioned
play that xbox doesn't have any games
like that and i will admit at this point
right now that's absolutely true for
some of the homies in the chat yo
playstation doesn't have a game like
gears they don't have a game like halo
you know i don't know some people say
kill zone but you know
so
both consoles have their positives and
negatives now at the same time
playstation is trying to do more
multiplayer games live service games and
xbox is trying to do more single-player
games so
both consoles i think are headed in
great direction to the first of
diversified their their portfolio to
make you know because
xbox is known for first-person shooters
playstation known for third person
adventure just to clarify dirt you're
not trying to play predator
like you're not trying to play
i'm good at it
now saying like
contrary to what people may believe or
may think uh
almost all xbox multiplayer-centric
games have like a
healthy community i know people you know
make fun of like halo for a steam thing
but obviously i just showed you you can
find it there's people still playing
halo infinite just people are unhappy
but they're still playing it sea of
thieves has one of the largest oh
absolutely
grounded has a community when that game
launches is only going to get bigger but
it hasn't actually helped between yeah
it does decay too which i don't play has
i love staying decay i love stuff can
they keep updating the game yeah
adding content that means that means
people are still playing it years are
still still healthy isn't it gear no no
no it's not
they'd be going crazy on these gears and
then they'd be trying to like like go
around the fact all of them have like
eight days in gears like this
it's like how is it so bad you have like
eight days in gears i don't get that
that's like me saying yo kid's smooth
destiny is garbage i'm done with it
but you got what's a thousand dollars in
it hold on let me i'm gonna i'm gonna
defend yourself let me respond to smooth
first hey move you said people playing
hello but they aren't happy with it
right
all right that that's a mental illness
and i think they need to go to some type
of psychiatrist or maybe go to church or
something that's that dog hey listen
i'm joking i'm joking look at it i'll
respond to you now as far as the gears
thing for me that's how i met my that's
how i met the squad that's why that name
that's why that game is near to me but
i'm gonna be real like we had people in
in the group who was dropping that joint
super early dropped it earlier it could
drop that earlier ricky dropped it early
like the only ones who was really
rocking on her like that was probably me
mark and audible now i had a chance to
get something so it's moving so
if i look up erica's hours right now
it's going to be low because she dropped
it early i don't know if it's going to
be no i think erica if you in the chat
tell me your hours i don't feel like
looking through your stuff
in the chat
you have been like 200 i know merc got
like 400 300 fo on it
jesus yeah he yeah it was going like it
was it's mostly king of the hill fuss
like you know what he was doing yeah um
look
giz is what it is it's yeah yeah erica
you check them out i know i know erica
got a ton of hours in them joining but
that's how i met them that's why that
game is like so near and dear to my
heart i was yo listen i was told oh
hustle if you like gears fives you're
gonna love the og trailer you wanna love
the og trilogy this is why i wanted that
remake to come out cause i tried playing
it on pc but it kept crashing them so it
was it's one of them things and two and
three aren't on pc but
i didn't want to take some time to clear
all that up
and smooth yeah you're right look a lot
of those games do have like fan bases uh
what was there's a i was kicking it with
dallas and baron one night oh hold up
erica calling you out this man also
ain't playing the campaign talk about it
so hustle i got a question for you did
you play the campaign to gears five no
but i played uh
shut up
shut up i told you i was late to that
now i got a problem saying that i was
late to that now
i didn't play it hold on i didn't play
uncharted until lost legacy and i went
back and played and played and beat the
majority of them games too felicia went
back and played them i know
second of all second of all erica
talking that bulls in the chat she don't
couldn't she knew first that i was gonna
run back through it all and there's live
streaming on my channel and all that so
miss me with the boost oh ella ella
keller
ella killer hustle is part of this
podcast it's all jokes i don't want to
hear don't kick him out ban him please
he ain't going to wish yeah stop all of
that
like talking like that the only thing
that's going to happen is you get timed
out because that it's jokes man this
isn't serious you said that oh he's
joking okay okay okay yeah i ain't going
nowhere anybody to be mad no but i'm not
i know that's but they know i was gonna
run through and shout out to acg because
he was the first one who kind of put the
battery in my back for me to play like
play through the whole series and give
my give a retrospective on it i was
trying to play it on pc but as you all
know that you know crashing on me so
like what are we talking about what are
we really talking about so it's not like
i wasn't trying to get it in like nah i
didn't miss me with the bs you missed me
with that plus hey listen man addict you
know how that is when people get to talk
about games
and they won't stop talking about it
it's like i i really felt like i was
missing something eric wouldn't stop
talking about the same thing with erica
they wouldn't stop talking about it so
i'm like all right let me let me at
least give it a try and like i got it on
the joint man just kept crashing what do
you want me to do
you can only take this real quick before
they go away five dollars from dawn
otaku if we talking uh if we really
talking about it splatoon 3 will top
last of us
and every other game coming out in
september
he's saying a cartoon game going to
smack your last of us how you feel about
that hey look hey that joint moved 20
million though
given how it rolled out do you think
halo should have been delayed this to
this fall would it have been better to
release it with co-op and forge maps
etcetera i agree with you um you know
i do feel like it should have been
delayed at least enough time to at least
get forge and co-op and maybe get a
little bit more of a thought process on
how they want to do these seasons
uh but here's the thing argy and i think
everyone on the panel and i think you
would even agree
at this point
saying the what-if game is useless like
we can't keep going on and on and say
what if they would have delayed halo
they didn't like we're just gonna have
to hey we're gonna have to like dig half
its grave and hope it don't have to dig
the rest like
and that's just my opinion on that is
anyone want to talk about that real
quick make a comment on that
no i mean
i think they had to get it out
they couldn't delay it anymore
so i guess maybe they figure hey it's a
live service game let's put this out
with the campaign multiplayer
and add everything else later
it's unfortunate but i think they had to
do what they had to do because
you know we couldn't go two whole years
with no first fighting games dude
okay so um let's go ahead and get this
super chat photo shoot from don otaku
xbox has no third person action games on
sony's level but sony don't have f
uh first person shooters survival open
road racers rts metro venus fighting
slims etc at all that is a good point i
think that's fair
as far as like third person they they're
definitely make arguably some of the
best in the industry i think you can
maybe have a good contestant rockstar
star makes better games than when it
comes to third person uh but you know
they they definitely make the top tier
in the franchise but is it okay for them
not to
make different types of games for other
people and i think that's that's a fair
argument i think that's why they are
doing that now
yeah we just have to see how they do it
though you know yeah i'm kind of curious
that they get that down all right so
now the the the star of the show man god
of war
so clearly you know first the first
thing we're we're going to talk about
the fiasco stuff going on with
you know there's been some harassment
stuff going on with the god of war
community talking to like uh some of the
devs and stuff to people that work there
people that used to work there we're
going to talk about
this insane
chronicle of we're in june the third and
we still don't have a release date and
people like corey barlog are still
coming out there kind of like kind of
like hinting it's coming out this year
so i want to talk about that first thing
you know
have you guys seen some of the crazy
stuff that these these are these fanboys
have been sending
um you know some of these developers
have you guys been seeing this
i hope you guys don't see it
no well
you heard about it
we heard about it
absolutely yeah so
look
one thing i want to say about this is
this is
where i've always stood when it comes to
this like you can't let
the small minority act like the majority
of that fan base it goes back to
you know a lot of majority
hey yo talk that stuff smooth
so okay smooth it's the majority why do
you think it's the majority because i
seen
way more of them than i did scene of the
pro i can name you on my fingers the
your act your level-headed playstation
gamers
but
and i argue with more than enough of
those weirdos so
um yeah i think it's the majority of
them act like that even if they don't
want to admit it uh just the way that
they go about talking about things and
addressing things it's just i'm not
surprised anymore i am not surprised and
um can you say that that toxic cities
and both
no i never stepped with it i said i
never sent phil spencer aaron greenberg
uh sarah bond any body parts
and i feel you on that i do feel you
like i i can't think of an incident
where i've seen an xbox fan go that far
but i i do feel like
it's like the two wrongs don't make a
right like look there are levels to this
oh my god i can't i gotta stop saying
that uh and i do think that's high up
there sending you know sending explicit
pictures of like that to like developers
and stuff
uh but you do see xbox people doing some
crazy stuff too
i i couldn't tell you anything that
drastic you know i've seen you know uh
xbox people uh you know make death
threats and stuff but i don't think i've
ever seen to the point where people were
sending pictures like that
and i i think i think it's
that's what i'm always saying like but
didn't this happen with the like the
last of us they got so mad that they
weren't announcing the release date that
they just leaked the whole damn game
no that was that was a developer that
was someone that was translating the
game
look that's why i feel like when it
comes to this
back when they were saying all the xbox
community are racist like you can't let
a couple people speak for everyone
and i'm very big on that
it's because it's like look there's bad
things that everyone even smooth did you
talk about the people you're talking
about what's that
10
to 50
people
but but that's still a small
drop in compared to all the god of war
fans
like
and i think that that's the thing for
god of war fans these are playstation
fans these dudes didn't care anything
about the original
uh trilogy of god award
like these are just like new bred
playstation fans that came up over the
last five years and they're just a new
breed of just weird uh it's like it's
the only thing the only if if god of war
was a multiplied game some something
that was published by 2k
or ubisoft or something like that nobody
would care
nobody would care dude is these
playstation fanboys they need
they need to be fed it's this fuel the
more you give me the more i can go after
these uh xbox fanboys that that's all it
is it all comes down to but i feel like
it's the other way around too like i do
feel like it's both ways like all these
these dudes went as far as getting how
many times they done got catfished three
times in one calendar year
catfish
one by somebody pretending to be
japanese
two uh guys pretending to be women and
they all infiltrate the playstation
community they've done they've done had
relations they've done sent people
playstations and tvs and stuff like that
it's all because of comfort so they've
gone way too far
they've gone way too far i did there's
nothing comparable to a playstation
fanboy there's there's xbox fanboys are
not on that level people can't stand
xbox fanboys for certain things because
we we have to wait till e3 we talk about
resolutions and 12 t flops these dudes
literally do real life
it's just impossible
isn't it funny when when smooth starts
talking bg just shows up out of nowhere
in the chat like a wild pokemon like
look smooth but smooth smooth is on to
something man
there's history of playstation fanboys
sending pics and dms man there's history
behind that
i'm not gonna say that smoove isn't
wrong i will say when it comes to like
the extremes usually you see the
playstation fanboy into that thing
uh that's why i say like
there's levels to this
don't underestimate the power of a
playstation fanboy so
you got the bottom you got the fanboys
on both sides that will go above and
beyond to fight that fanboy ward then
you got the fans above that and i think
the majority of us fall along in that
you know what i'm saying uh you know
smoove might be a little bit between the
last two he's not directly on the bottom
but he's definitely not there
uh and then you got like uh the the
quote-unquote neutrals that i don't
think exist
very few uh and i think the majority of
the neutrals that you that actually
exist is the casual gamers that don't
really care what platform they buy they
just buy a platform for like exactly
call of duty
2k like i'm a fan i could that's why i
never like luca
like i've never willingly let myself get
like labeled as a fanboy and you know i
know she she jokingly does that because
like when you make content and you get
labeled as something because i've always
felt myself as a fair content creator
sure i do lean one way there's no
denying that i am a fan of the xbox
brand but i have definitely put them to
the fire multiple times i put x
playstation to the fire multiple and
that's why like i'm very adamant on
trying not to be labeled as one i
clearly me what's funny is me being
smoove's friend over the years is
naturally i'm a i'm a fan boy by by
association like just by association it
is what it is i don't really go too much
into it anymore uh it doesn't most
people are fanboys it is what it is
glad dirk my bad
look i just want to say this right quick
at the end of the day
are there
people we wish wasn't in our community
absolutely on both sides right
absolutely but
when it comes down to it
tell me if i'm wrong i don't know if you
guys know it now i have never seen
a xbox fanboy
attack a playstation fanboy oh all right
let me explain
i had a playstation fanboy attack me
now he's african-american i'm obviously
african-american
this dude called me uncle tom strictly
because i am a xbox fan i don't know
oh you know what i'm talking about see
listen he went i said i've talked to
luca she said he said the same stuff to
her yikes a lot bunch of other people
this guy attacks he's a black guy and he
attacks all black xbox content creators
he called us coons and everything else
yeah i don't know if any xbox guy has
done that but i haven't seen it and
that's what i'm saying like because
xbox's uh own uh is i guess is american
a white american company and i don't i
guess if we were to have that loyalty to
a japanese company we're considered like
in the mix yeah it's crazy for the
culture for the culture it's crazy for a
japanese company what are we doing so
so of course so of course there's toxic
people in any community i've seen in the
sports communities movie communities any
community absolutely make a community
talk about it they put a whole draco out
on somebody in the city
who don't know absolutely we're no
listen but at the end of the day what
we're specifically talking about i'm
trying to ask who's more toxic let's be
real
[Laughter]
that's not a problem because at the end
of the day each thing that caused an
xbox to pull out a gun on camera was
them being attacked personally
they were verbally assaulted and so they
wanted to set the level state now nobody
was harmed because you ain't going to
shoot your computer screen
that's not going to happen it is just
like hey shut up
so i i rather like i feel like
it's not a big deal
compared to what these playstation guys
have been doing
i would rather you pull out a show me
that you got a you got a draco than
anything because then i'm less likely to
bother your ass and i know something
like that you know what i mean like
places you guys give me like
like you don't
deserve to be anywhere in a school
district vibe like
this
community type
oh damn background checks
you know before you come through
damn smooth
well well dirk are you finished i kind
of want to answer the question man
i mean yeah i'm just saying you know
there's toxic people in all communities
yeah but this specific topic we're
talking about yeah is about some
playstation fanboys um you know
there was one guy that hit me up because
i did a video about this topic
dude how do you know it was a
playstation fanboy how you know it
wasn't the xbox fanboy acting like shut
up
that's the first thing they wanted to
how you know cuz cuz y'all have a track
record but
um
this specific issue is just it's it's
absolutely unacceptable bro but i'm
sorry go ahead uh
yeah um under no circumstances would i
ever condone
that type of behavior from from
just many places but from anybody like
yo don't play like that that's first of
all you can get locked up that's sexual
assault and get locked up for that um
don't play like that and you shouldn't
even put yourself out there like that no
way um
as far as corey
you know saying that hey this game is
coming out later i got a theory behind
that not i didn't come up with this
theory on my own i actually heard
somebody say it first i just forgot who
said it i feel like y'all know the
snitch on twitter i feel like they he's
an internal cat whoever he is right
whoever this gentleman or young lady is
i feel like they just throwing bait out
there just to be like all right cool we
got him because like he's been like dead
right on like and 100
wannabes so i feel like they're trying
to flush whoever that is i feel like
they're trying to flush him out do i
believe that this god of war is coming
out um later on this year yeah i i
definitely do believe i think so now too
yeah i think what not but i had always
thought so because a lot of people when
they saw that that's gotta want to take
a play they was like i think it was
david jaffe was like saying something to
the effect that looked like dlc or
something shout out to jeffy
they are super chatting playstation
fanboys doing crazy stuff now oh my god
oh my god
i forgot about about the david jaffee
attack i forgot about that yeah
let's read these super chats uh let's
hope we get through these before they
start to afford there is a lot of
incidences there is a lot of incidents
you got to be reminded by some of them
right now
okay let me make sure it's not above
this
uh
no i read that one okay we gotta find
out subject from hardkey chaney
ponies are sending
you know pics to sony devs but tea
bagging is sexual harassment oh man
i saw that and i kind of laughed
i
mean
we could briefly talk about that
uh five dollars from dan lorenzo ps
apologists always say xbox does it to bs
it's only weird ps dudes
and it's a majority of them stop saying
xbox does it too that's [ __ ] i'm not
saying xbox does it too i just here
here's
my intentions behind those statements is
i don't want everyone thinking
it's like everyone in the playstation
community that that was my interest
of course because once you start
labeling something as everyone that's
when stuff gets out of hand like we
don't need general of course labels we
need there is some toxic playstation and
xbox fanboys and they speak loud and
everyone gets labeled and that's all i
was saying
about it five dollars from donna taco oh
no it's alex channel confirms that all
ps fanboys are the same
[Laughter]
playstation videos okay now alex forget
who we get but we can't let them off the
hook even them pc dudes they they they
win they races et cetera et cetera all
them communities all of these
communities that's what i'm saying every
one of them has people in it all of them
all any community not just gaming not
just gaming neither the car community is
god awful this community oh my god
listen this [ __ ] community is crazy and
if i find that video i'm gonna make sure
i hit you up with it
um smooth fix your face your camera
because you're watching that's a little
blurry okay focus yeah now
all all of it is bad man i feel like as
a community we got to like exile
all of it all all the negative whatever
you got to especially when it comes to
sending us a list of their pictures to
you know that's what we're doing
don't do that
i feel that talking trash is fine as
long as it doesn't get personal or
disrespectful and sometimes it goes
there unfortunately
that's what i've always said like look
like you could disagree with someone and
you know smoove can
test i've said this for years have i not
you can easily get your point across
without being disrespectful have i not
said that for years yeah yeah
and you know it's just like look like i
get it
some people feel like they need that
disrespect to make content better
but it's just like you can easily make
it without it like
and that that's the part that it annoys
me that people
don't do it because they want to do it
they do it because they feel like they
need to do it
you got to file a treatment from gamer
by choice based on what i see in the
world people in general are weird people
are fanboys and coasters in sports
religion politics and unfortunately
gaming i will say there
it's it's it's like that everywhere i
will say that okay now we got the
tyson
butcher that 15th super chat i've only
seen a doctor share outpatient
informations for consoles catfishing for
only fans and screaming disrespectfully
to developers cause of his opinion on a
podcast from playstation fans
look look man i i gotta point look you
guys are making good points
but it's on each side like
you guys are making it hard to say that
uh
yeah i forgot about it too until i read
that super chat shout out to target for
the five dollars to find out tea bag in
style with 2 200 halo credits global
code uh so shout out to anyone that
snatched those man those credits
look
i don't
this is all i'm saying when it comes to
it is like look
you guys can easily
zone in on the people doing it and not
on the whole community that's the whole
point about it so let's let's gravitate
towards the actual god of war being
delayed god of war coming out so many
people saying this so many people saying
that we're in july we still got a
release date so i'm going to go through
this circle we've done this multiple
times we gotta do it again unfortunately
we gotta do it again
hustle no we're gonna like save hustle
for last because he's got a spirit bomb
from the chat
um kid smooth is god will come out this
year
no
no okay
dirk does god of war come out this year
i think yes because corey barlow seems
like he's pretty confident you know he's
i think you know i think it comes out
too hustle yeah does god will come out
this year yes yes yes one thousand times
yes with everything that we've seen from
it from
accessibility day how they had you know
how they
how they did they did the promo on
twitter everything's a rollout um y'all
have heard me say that before y'all
gonna hear me say it again you won't
hear me said yet again you're gonna hear
me say it a thousand times everything is
a roll out
everything everything that you think
that ain't a rollout for promotion is a
roll off for promotion with the
exception of probably that that whole
lewd picture thing i don't think nobody
won't put that out there's promotion but
everything that we see on twitter in
terms of the promotion for this game in
particular from the state of play on
what is promotion dog so everything's
promotion uh when yeah they leaked the
price to the last of us in the in the
release date that was promotion
i truly believe so what about when they
leaked this whole game of last week
whether it's intentional or
unintentional i feel like everything
you see you see that early release they
didn't do nothing that joint still sold
10 million you see it didn't do nothing
it was bundled with playstations too
so i'm just joking i'm joking
okay let me let me come here
let me call let me let me calm down my
phone let me calm down but it doesn't
matter but everything's a rollout though
everything is everything is a roll out
whether it's intentional unintentional
the second they hit twitter like you
know what it's gonna do especially if it
take off like i'm not saying all of us
good promotion but like when you see it
and when you see things take off when
you see things start to trend it's like
oh yo let's take advantage of that the
business minded hustle just just take it
there like that it's like oh we can we
can use this to capitalize off of
whatever it is
now that we've seen entirely too much
from this game and
i ain't got no sources i'm not wonton
shout out to wonton i'm not the snitch
i'm not none of them but i i truly
believe that this game comes out
let him be great anyhoo i definitely
think that this game is coming out this
year because out of everything that
we've seen from it is
i would let's put it this way and i've
always said this and i don't know if i'm
wrong whatever i'm wrong
it's just one of those things i would be
disappointed if it didn't come out this
year because we've seen a lot from that
game we we sent corey ballard just tweet
oh wait we're not ready to show nothing
yet and then he turned right back around
and be like no but don't worry y'all
still coming out this year he'll tweet a
picture with his wife don't worry i got
awards coming out this year i'm just
having this fine steak dinner with my
wife and all that
i would be extremely disappointed if it
didn't come out this year just based off
of what we're seeing from actual
developers not from nobody else but just
from from corey himself and he's not the
director of this game by the way i think
there's another gentleman who's the
director of this game but cory is
definitely promoting this damn game
y'all so
i'd be surprised if we didn't come out
this year that's all
you know what i think corey barlock has
just been a little bit too active on
twitter for not to come out this year
like you just said he's been very active
he's been talking a lot somebody is
probably coming out now as me as me and
my um xbox fanboy channel you know we
hope it doesn't come out i just want to
talk trash but he's a fan of god
okay let me breathe as a fan of god of
war though i don't want the game to come
out so i can play it but hey man
i fight ain't no games this year yeah
you know what's funny i mean there's a
couple multiplats you know but yeah i
king right now on whether or not it
comes out this year
i'm on the yes kings on the no and i was
thinking myself
if i lose i still win sure i gotta bend
the knee on camera and you know that
that might be a little king gonna have
his little way with that but i still get
it i still get it talk by snap
and if i win
king got to bend the knee on camera to
me like
we got a super chat uh this is going to
be interesting find out here from john
dutaku uh addict did you see foxy uk
video talking about you and why final
fantasy can't be on xbox
i did see that funny story i saw that
from watching oh no it's alex
didn't even know that video exists until
i watched that look
uh you know if you make a video about me
just just just pronounce my name right
that's all ass pronounce my name
um just clowning on my uh the tweet i
made saying that final fantasy
uh needs to be on xbox and he went to
this like i don't know it's kind of like
a circle of like confusing statements
like
that we ain't going to go out there you
know you guys want to watch that you go
watch that find out superstar from
donataku god of war ragnarok would have
came out this year but when king david
said it's coming out 2023
and the universe followed his plan
because he's 97 percent of the right
time right yeah that's true what about
that three though what about that three
you know my list wars revolves around
that three that's where that three
percent man that list thor's revolves
around that three i got a question for
you guys before we head out because
we're about to uh close this up
i'm buying uh we're about to get a
headset for for the girl man because she
uh she wants to
play more games co-op what's a good
headset like a headset you got on yeah i
was about to say
hold up hold up hold up i need a headset
that has a 3.5 jack too oh oh
wired version of that the wire but see
look it's got to be a wireless that has
enabled you to go wired if you want to
or something similar i mean maybe i
could do that but here here's the issue
like we were playing fall guys this
headset was horrible man it was
it was horrible so put i just want
i want options that's all i want like
obviously we got this headset uh what's
funny is uh i had to fix this headset
because it was breaking i actually think
this is one of the best headsets on the
market it's just the mic is not that
good they need to they need a better mic
and i feel like these ear muffs need to
be a little bit slightly bigger
but besides that i love i love these
that they can bluetooth with stuff
that's the kind of options i need you
know maybe it doesn't need to be
connected
to with a 3.5 jack
it needs to have like a bluetooth uh
enabled as well where you could actually
hook up to bluetooth so put in the
comment section put in the in the chat
tell me some good headsets for this
chick man because you know she she she
spent a hundred dollars on destiny
you're a content creator you should know
this uh yeah i don't buy something like
that
i'm not doing something right now for
you i don't buy headsets like that yo
i've had this headset for three years
still serious it's still serious
what man they used to do
platronics and stuff like that
i don't know what because that play
charlie's got issues bad maybe the new
ones maybe
i tell you this um you can't really go
wrong with the sennheiser gaming headset
in terms of audio but they don't because
they don't beat us around on that um
alex was the one who actually because i
used to wear like the dr the beats by
dre and all that for like headphones
from my mix and all that
these these little cheek joints i might
have spent like 70 80 dollars for these
this isn't a headset you don't know how
much these costs what's up honey
nah like 30 bucks yeah they look pretty
cheap look look look at the
look at the earmuffs they look like
they're crumpled
i'm gonna drop this on twitter for you
um in terms of the microphone quality
i'm not sure however in terms of like
for the first time with these headphones
in particular like i could hear people
like walk up on me with them beats i
couldn't hear people like when i'm
playing multiplayer games i couldn't
hear them like sneak up behind me and
all that so there's a bit of truth with
sennheiser like i'll stand by them now
and i just did that based off of the
fact that you know cause i got
recommendation from uh from alex he
recommended a long time ago but
these ones that i'm about to link you
they are
hundred
140
forty yeah they're like 140 they come
with a microphone and everything do a
little research on it first but
now if your old lady need you know some
some headphones go send hazard first
because like them to join not turtle
beach i didn't i didn't fell into that
trap with turtle beach you all know
about y'all but like i actually was
looking at the turtle beach second
series like 120 bucks or something like
that don't do it don't do it i haven't
found that trap before buddy
absolutely not yeah i only have a turtle
beaches yeah them and them joints was
like
man i was trying to give me a earring
man yeah i only care for them i was
super geek to try and run with them join
us i was like oh i'm gonna be like a
call of duty player this oh my i was so
green i got them joined some of them
always broke on me and everything else
this is back in like the the ps3 days
i'm like nah i said i'll never do that
again but people check the dm
people in the chat um the reason the
attic show
is on sunday instead of wednesdays
because uh king's birthday so he's out
of town and cogs like
like
he's where rand lives wherever rand
lives i don't know what chicago chicago
yeah around that area uh so i figured
you know we uh because i know there's a
lot of you that haven't tried out the
attic show and you know we do this every
wednesday at 5 p.m uh dirt's like a
rotating member whenever he can make it
because uh he busy dude and hustle it's
usually me and hustle us you know this
is the only other time smooth ever gonna
be on this podcast because he usually
works during that time all right so can
i say something that yeah sure shout out
to dirk and smoove i wish they both were
available more often like i i like i'm
feeling the panel energy right now like
i really enjoy like this dynamic that we
got going on yeah
you know you got playing at xbox the
same day we do you know attic show but
it'd be cool if every now and again you
you gracious with your presence it'd be
great
i'm trying to approach i try to approach
kids to move from playing at xbox i'm
gonna be real i could do both
does the show too early because even if
i didn't do playing xbox on wednesdays
um i still got to work yeah i'd have two
of the show to like seven to eight yeah
if smooth wanted to be on it like full
time
but you know yeah i know hustle has like
issues on staying up late so that's
probably would never be an option
well
i'll say this i'll say this i'm willing
to concede some of the way my new job is
going to have me be at work at 5 45 so
you know
yeah you got to be there
you know the thing i get off man early
though i get off at like 1 30 in the
afternoon it's not like though yeah it's
not the it's not but it's a trade-off
you got to find somewhere to like sleep
you can't like be up here yeah i
definitely came man yeah so it's and
it's always been like that that's why i
was with um i was on upp in the very
beginning but i just couldn't do it
because i was waking up 5 30 in the
morning and all that so it was it's the
thing that i just couldn't do it but
you know i'll be willing to concede some
of the time i just don't want to be like
throwing it off with none of it so
that's that's the one y'all like hey
what's up what's up i won't put that
well put that out there now we'll talk
about it all right so you know i
appreciate everyone coming through man
uh you know i wasn't going to talk about
cuphead but i realized no one here
played it
um
yeah no
apparently did you play cuphead no you
know
you played if you want i bought it i
never finished the bumblebee off of the
first one
oh man that bumblebee kept whooping me
am i saying man after this game
hey i got a question about that did they
ever fix the pairing because uh in the
first one um
still a little inconsistent i feel like
you have a better chance of paying if
you come up from above and not like
jumping into it uh but i enjoyed it i
beat the first boss uh got real close to
beating the second a couple times but i
had to go i don't know that's why i
could never be uh like a like i'd have
to maybe if i had because where people
don't
people know me for podcasting not
streaming so i do feel like if i can
stick with it for a couple months and
get a decent chat going i could probably
stream longer i just get bored you know
what i'm saying like no
there is chat interaction but not as
much as like a podcast so i like hour
have two i'm ready to go you know what
i'm saying but you know i appreciate
everyone coming through man kids been
working to find where can they find you
admin uh find me on twitter actually
smooth youtube channel kiss move you got
my 13 000 followers on on
twitter now don't you 14 000 oh flex i
seen uh but i still can't i still don't
got the check mark so it's
not
i mean um
but yeah still trying to get these
t-shirts off into the am dot com slash
kids smoothie let me see that t-shirt
let's see you matter what the hell is
that it's an astronaut
astronaut
what is he does he got blood going down
it's kind of like lava or something like
that but it's lava okay so we got some
suitable graphic tees 10 off everything
in the store when you use that link so
what what
what's the link
into the am dot com slash kid smooth
let me get these super chats real quick
before i hand it off to the rest um
[Music]
man people keep changing okay find out
from donald talk i know attic didn't
just tell someone to get his name right
all right spell my name right fi two
dollars from donnataku when you gonna
stream dookudooku literature club
people have asked me to stream that game
multiple times and i feel like i would
be very creeped out by that game i've
seen a couple cut scenes
like very vaguely stuff about i don't
know i'll think about it we'll see we'll
see
uh where where people find you out dirt
what's going on with you late like
no months man you know check out my
channel uh dirk griggity got wbz xbox
podcast actually tomorrow um i know it's
the fourth but i ain't doing nothing
might as well do the podcast right um
uh tomorrow night on my channel at 6 30
pm eastern time
uh yeah so check out my show i um you
know i do my podcast i do regular videos
i also do another um podcast on fridays
uh tts podcast which of course means
talk that sh
on my boy sean 786 uh channel so we you
know we do that every friday so yeah you
know and like adam mentioned i'll be
here on some wednesday some wins as i
can't make it
but uh yeah guys so excuse me um so you
might have if i put my
makeup yeah that's fine you don't have
to ask oh okay
so that's about it guys yeah you know
wants to follow all these uh individuals
on twitter man just not kid smooth yeah
i gotta catch up on my woman twitter
followers before you can start following
kids but might take me 10 15 years by
then he'll be at like 20 25 000. so i
guess you might as well just go ahead
and follow smoothie because i'm never
gonna catch up to him but i appreciate
her coming through man we're going to go
ahead and close this out wait a minute
wait a minute me we ain't talking about
hustle you had you got gut punched all
day now i'm joking
hey listen listen um the youtube channel
is going through some restructuring i'm
finna just do like retrospectives that's
kind of what i enjoy doing but as far as
the live streams because i still will be
doing that um twitch follow me on twitch
and twitter and youtube so just i'm
gonna give everybody a reason to like go
follow me catch me here every week uh
every wednesday regardless of what job
is hand in the chat today i ain't going
nowhere you offended me man and this
friend they get worse for either me or
y'all and i got my money on me so you
know y'all make sure y'all follow me um
make sure you follow what is smooth is
weapon well coming onto that oh no what
the smoove is eating
she don't even know
all right well all right every weekend
every sunday at 5 45. y'all make sure
y'all catch weapon will y'all make sure
y'all catch they're greg at these
podcasts every monday as well today i
want to thank y'all for just you know
coming being part of this man this this
was fun i i had a good time
regardless of regardless of what was
happening i i literally had a good time
and
now it's always cool to see us like come
together um shout out to the lords happy
belated birthday to king david um we
didn't also didn't we didn't have a show
last week because my birthday was on
tuesday
and i think i was coming in here on that
one i'll be belated brother yeah yeah
again i replayed it brother
appreciate it appreciate you and um
thank y'all for joining us shout out to
mercy
um
shout out to bg in the chat for trying
to bully smooth shout out to erica in
the chat for trying to bully me and um i
really do look at it this is always fun
man i always have a good time here for
it's like i said anyone in the chat man
every wednesday 5 p.m we we at it again
uh you know until further notice i don't
know if we'll have a show this wednesday
because we had a sunday
i guess it would depend on what happens
this week if something happens like
monday or tuesday we'll justify coming
out and speaking then maybe we'll have a
show wednesday or i get like a big guess
now some people spoke to concern of like
my uh if we don't have a show wednesday
i will post the the interview i did last
week that will go up wednesday because
i've been editing it uh you know it's
it's not it's not a game i'm sure a lot
of you in the chat won't care about
because it's a it's a turn-based game
but if it is
ready i will have it wednesday and you
know who knows sometimes people be
dropping some crazy news on mondays but
if there's nothing crazy we will be
skipping a week we'll give everyone a
little bit of a vacation
and then we'll be back next week uh so i
appreciate ever coming through and until
next time this is addict hustle dirt
griggity and kid smooth we'll see you
next time peace out